[音楽]
勝ったぞー
ついに来ました年末ジャンボ宝くじ
710万円分
開封します
[音楽]
内藤笑っても負けるしかありません去年
Twitterの方でリツイートされた数
かける100円分年末ジャンボ宝くじ買い
ますって言ったところ
7.1番について頂きました7.1万×
100710万円710万円分の宝くじ
買ってきましたその説は皆さんどうも
ありがとうございましたまずありがとう
感謝してるだって今から710万どころ
じゃなく10億円になるからな
710万円分買ってきましたよもう気合の
入り方が違うよ今回どうやって710万円
分買ったかというと宝くじ売り場ってこう
当たりやすいとか今まですごい当たった
宝くじ売り場ってあるんですけども全国の
当たると言われている宝くじ売り場から
買い集めてきました合計6か所から買って
きましたこの列が神奈川県の横浜
ダイヤモンドチャンスセンター
めっちゃ当たると言われてるところですで
ここ
東京の西銀座チャンスセンターで僕が1
時間半待ちで買ってきましためっちゃ
当たると言われてますでここ静岡県の鈴木
タバコ店という宝くじ売り場静岡だと
ここって言われてる宝くじ売り場ですで
ここが愛知名駅前チャンスセンターこれも
愛知で当たると言われている宝くじ売り場
でここが富山県富山県の太郎丸チャンス
センターそしてここが大阪
駅前
第4ビル前特設会場大阪で買ってきた
宝くじですで合計710万円分各売り場
120万円分円盤60万から60万
バランスよく買ってきました
120万120万円120万円
120万120万東京の西銀座だけ
110万円分で合計710万円分です
まずは普通に心臓止まりそうただ皆さん俺
は今回当てる気であの生きていますだって
当たったら10億円でしょ710万円分
あるんでしょだから100万円分とかは
聞いたことあるんですけど710万円
分かったYouTuber聞いたことね俺
は今日ファミリー出すぞー
すいません取り乱しましたというわけで
シンプルに710万円分の宝くじを買っ
たら何円分当たるのかやっていきたいと
思います
僕1人でやろうと思ったんですけども
ちょっと
超有名俳優さん連れてきましたお願いし
ます
はい
超有名スーパースターのイケメンですおー
イケメン来ました
何円ぐらい当たると思ういやまずは10億
は必ず当たるとして10億3000万
[音楽]
えーっと全部当たります
嘘です1回この動画がひげ切ったところで
早速年末を開けていきましょう基本的に
7頭の300円になるんですけども下一桁
が1だったらその時点で300円当たり
ますメンバーもまだもう基本的に下一桁は
1234567890になってるんで絶対
3000円分買ったら300円は返って
くるようになってますつまり10%は返っ
てくるから710万円分買って71万円分
は絶対返ってくるだってそこからですよ7
頭がまあ300円6とか3000円この
3000円カスタムとかなりの金額になり
ます5等が1万円これもこれだけあれば
どれだけ出るかわかんない1万円4等が
5万円3と100万円2と1000万円
ぶっちゃけこれでいいですそして1頭が
7億円81組の
128387これが出れば7億円です
そしてその1等の前後賞81組の
12838828386
前後小が出れば1億5000万ドル
1億5000万で10億になるとバナナと
前後賞はないんですけども連番だっ50億
の可能性があると1頭の組討が衣装81組
じゃないけど数字が合っててやつが
10万円となっておりますどうする注目
やったら初めて
とりあえず
9をこれがもらえますねでもマジで銃を
買っとったら普通に丸の内に100万円と
かこうやって俺ポイントあげちゃうから
お前には1万円な1万すかというわけで
早速710万円分開けていきましょう
今回わかりやすく当たったクズをすぐ
入れるように準備しました100万以上が
出たらここたまってきます4等の5枚が
出るとここ5頭の1万円がここ
6頭の3000ここ
7頭のためにここ上限出たらもうここに
置いてきます
お前は運命の瞬間に立ち上がるわけだ
すごいなんで坊主にしたんだこの日のため
にかこの日のために
言うなじゃあ行かせていただきますまずは
神奈川県横浜ダイヤモンドチャンス
センターの見ていきましょうマジで銀座
ちょっとやばいちょっとこれ数字見落とし
たりするとマジでやばいのでダブル
チェックでやりたいと思いますよろしくお
願いしますちなみにサブさんの算数とか
できますから
全くできません
90万まで来たけど
待ってとりあえずこれ300円でしょ
3000円ゲットーはい
96番下2桁
速攻で3000円ゲットしましたまあ先
いいよね
幸先はいいですね
[音楽]
お3000円ゲットようやく3000円が
2枚
[音楽]
128387はい
81ぐらい
絶対嘘じゃんマジマジやばいやばい絶対
嘘なんだよ
お3000円きましたー
[音楽]
はい
380万円
ないですおい1等見ろありましたお前
やばいマジで
3000円ゲットでーす
6頭ぐらいは割と出ますなだからほんと5
頭とかからは急激に出ない気がする
多分今15万円分ぐらいやりましたけど
結構疲れますねこれ入って分かってても
新品です
胃腸にだけだけど380
番台
ますね
[音楽]
3000円
3000円ゲットーでかいなんか定期的に
6とは出ますね3000円はただ1万円と
かまでなかなか出ないんだけど
壁かサービス俺がザルカのどっちか
絶対ザルおーやめときました本当に
[音楽]
3000円
3000円3000円
631ラーメンもないなこれ今日も
後藤1万円当たりましたやったーすごい
ようやくここに来てゴッドを渡りました
325で
下3桁5頭ですやったーやっとここに
置けるよいつもねでかいでかいよ貴重貴重
拾ったの
70万円超えたあたりからマジで
記憶ない
100は
下一桁の1もちょっと覚えてるね
ありますね1
本当に
通常もう抹茶バラムズすぎ本当にやばい
じゃあ俺が見落としてたやつ1個見つける
ために1000円ずつはうわー
お願いします
[音楽]
人毛の違うのある一等の
うわやべー
だるい
皆さん一等が128387なんですけど
すいません全然首も違うんですけどこれ
138387でしたいやー
組違うけどこんだけ近いとちょっと
ドキッとしましたね
うわちょっと頑張ります
3000円
おおおおと1万円です2枚目の1万円出
ました
着実に出ては来ている
疲れたー
3000円3000円
3000円
[音楽]
おおえ5と1万円よしよしよしよしよし
3000円
[音楽]
はじめさん1
桁1番ありました1万円おめでとうござい
ます
やったー
3000円
何するっすか
右翼は
自分の好きなように使いますであとの1億
はいろんなお世話になった人とかサブとか
で
配って残りの8億をどう使うかななんか
動画に使ったりとか家の何かに使ったりと
かそういう感じかな
全部パチンコ
[音楽]
頭の1万円です
嬉しそうじゃないな
断然
おっ3000円
[音楽]
いやなんかなんやかんやん出てるぞことは
4と4桁1810から全然出ない
おー1万円5と1万円ですなんかねピース
上がってきたねえ5頭は割とデート1万円
[音楽]
順番の100倍時間かかる本当に
すごい番号数見てこれすごいよ
えすごい皆さん見てくださいこれ番号が
100000ですめっちゃ綺麗これは特別
ボーナスショーで1億円とさせていただき
ます
[音楽]
すごいね
すごいこれ
皆さん見てくださいこれなんと番号
1414141と4が交互に繰り返されて
ますこれ1億4千万円
ボーナス
[音楽]
そんなことある今バラを何枚か開けてるん
ですけど見えるかなんかすごい綺麗な数字
続きみたいになっててちょっと
怖いんすよねなんか今バラって適当な数字
だからなんかこんなに揃うことないと思う
んでちょっと怖いなんか
えサービスもう
[音楽]
怖い怖い怖いやばい絶対ドッキリじゃん
いやいやいやどうやってさすがに宝塚の中
までいじれないよはい皆さんまた来ました
何が起きてんのこれ普通になんか怖いんだ
けど
[音楽]
ふざけてるぞこれ普通にはいまた来ました
次は7と8が交互に来てます
皆さんまた来ましたすげえいつと9だけ
です
数字ですごい規則性を感じるんですけど
何これ
まいっかあやっときました3000円
3000円
おーっと3000円
300円
3000円
[音楽]
横浜の全部終わりましたー
メンバーは数字がそのまま繋がってるので
パート見れるんですけどバナナがもう数字
がバラバラすぎて
確認するのにものすごく時間がかかります
というわけでちょっと神奈川県の
120万円分で当たった総額確認してみ
ましょう120万円分連番が60万円から
60万円分買った結果
7等の300円これは10万セット買えば
連番のバラも必ず1枚入ってるので400
枚ありました12万円6と3000円40
枚ありました12万円分5頭の1万円がえ
6万円あたりましたね6万円分で合計
12万+12万+6万でぴったり30万円
でしたマイナス90万円
どうすんのこれマジでやばいって普通に
どうしようすいません多分これこのまま
あと5店舗やってると
4日はかかりますマジで4日はかかるので
1回ちょっと連番だけ全部終わらせ
ましょう
第1点字が来ましたよろしくお願いします
ちょっと2人だとマジで一応終わらない気
がしたのでちょっと手伝っております
うんの方はどうですか
僕去年は最悪でしたね
帰ってもらっていいですか
[音楽]
運悪いんだけどこういうなんか抽選系とか
当たる系の運はあるタイプだと思ってて
それ以外はもう運がない
じゃあ行きましょうかお願いします
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
わ
なかなか5万が出てこないバラじゃない
からそうかそう規則性が逆にありすぎて変
な当たり方しないんだよね逆にバツに
当たれば召喚ってくるっていう
何つったら今
俺なんかめっちゃ今こんなこと
はい
愛知県名駅前チャンスセンターの連番を見
終わりました
円盤だと全然1万円とかはなかったですね
ただ確実に300円と3000円は出
たっていう感じですというわけで連番全部
開けたところ
7頭の300円が200枚6等の
3000円が20枚で5件12万円当たり
ました
順番は楽だけど1万円とか出ないから
当たった時はバーンと多分高額出るん
でしょうけどもなかなか
普通に辛いですはいというわけで次行き
ましょう
次は大阪府の大阪駅前第4ビル前に特設
会場大阪など連番の60万円分開けていき
たいと思います
来ました
午後1万円ですいや全般で5頭はなかなか
珍しいさっきなかったですからねことを
さっきよりかはいいかもしれない
と
俺の名前なんだっけ
5と1万円ですいや大阪ちょっと調子いい
よ
5頭1万円
多さがええなあ
1万円です
5と1万円
よし大阪
終わりました大阪の連番
7頭の300円が200枚で6万円6トン
の3000円20枚で6万円5頭の1万円
がなんと5枚出て5万円5件17万円
当たりました
うーん
名古屋に比べると結構当たったんですけど
もバチバチのマイナスです次行きましょう
はい
次は東京の西銀座チャンスセンターです
僕が買ってきましたますっげー並んでて
めっちゃ当たるって言われてるところで
期待できると思います
[音楽]
ではこれ波来てるよマジでまずちょっと
しっかり行こうここは
頼んだしっかり見ようはい
1万円
5と1万円
[音楽]
あー
足りました
1万円ちょっと
録画といて
来ました5と1万円
おっと一番イエーイ
1万円
[音楽]
1万円いやいや
銀座すごいぞマジでめっちゃ出るよ1万円
ぐらいなら
1万円
すごいね
めっちゃ1万円出てるはい以上になります
高額当選はなかったもののかなり5頭の
1万円が出てる印象がありました300円
が200枚3000円が20万円5頭の
1万円がなんと8本出ております銀座の
レバー20万円でしたいやすごいめっちゃ
高い方だと思って普通に
[音楽]
次は富山県はじめしゃちょーの地元の富山
県の太郎丸チャンスセンターの連番60枚
分けていきたいと思います
結構ねもう見落としとかしそうなんで割と
ギリギリなんですけどもとりあえず連番
だけはやりきましょう我々の手で
[音楽]
いつも通り7等が200枚6頭の
3000円が20枚合計12万円で
ことはゼロでした
なるほどというわけで
連番のラスト
我らが地元
静岡の鈴木タバコ店でやっていきたいと
思いますもう静岡県内だと思う最強レベル
でしょ最強ですここはその
腕愛かり
おーえ1万円
早い
すごい静岡
1発人
あるよこれワンチャンちょっと待って待っ
て結構
どうした
[音楽]
メンバーのラストですね
300円と3000円でした
お疲れ様でした
こんなに出ないもんなんだただ静岡に関し
ては5頭の1万円が
折ってたより出てた気がします中継の結果
静岡では
7度の300円が200枚3000円が
20枚そしてなんと5頭の1万円が10本
10万円合計22万円でした
[拍手]
これがさ10万円分買って22万とかだっ
たら
60万なんですよ
バチバチのマイナスでございますちょっと
連番は3人で何とか見れたんですけども
バラはちょっとそういうなんか機会があ
るっぽくてそちらの機会の方に持って行か
せていただいて確認しようと思いますただ
まだ諦めたわけじゃねーちょっと
待ってます今日のところはおやすみ
[音楽]